this video is very very late I mean I
should have finished this about three
weeks ago but I didn't and so I've
devised a creative punishment for myself
so here we go
well hello person of the internet my
name is Charlie and in today's movie I'm
going to be giving you some vital
information so I hope your brains are
set to absorb yeah basically on the 8th
of August 2008 there is going to be a
YouTube gathering happening in Toronto
personally I would love to go to it but
unfortunately I do not have enough money
to go to freakin Canada coincidentally I
also know a lot of other UK youtubers
who would love to go to the gathering
but do not have the resources so for
those people or just anyone else who
wants to meet up I have devised a plan
well I mean I I say I devised a plan but
you know I kind of just drew a picture
of a baby alien but I can come up with a
plan off the top of my head that's cool
you just watch me the plan is right I'm
going to be holding my own eight eight
eight gathering right here in the UK so
yeah thing is it's not actually going to
be on the egg for baldness it's gonna be
on the first of august so it's not
really an eight eight eight gathering
but you know to say we look fat so like
I said the gathering is going to be on
the 1st of August it's going to start at
12 noon and it's going to be in
Leicester Square in London because that
is the cliche place for UK gatherings to
happen and I want to be cliche however
you're probably thinking Charlie
congratulations you're holding your own
gathering well done whatever but what
does David have to do with any of this
huh
David mmm well girlfriends right I got
some news for you up until now I have
not did the way the gatherings have been
named gatherings have always been named
in various different ways and they've I
have been called 888 or 777 after the
date in which they occur or they've been
named after the person who organised
them like narrow Mons narrow fest or
they haven't been named at all it's just
been the September gathering and that is
all about to change
on this day I've decided that my
gathering deserves its own proper name
which is why I'm calling it David um so
I hope to see you all at David on the
1st of August yes I realized that this
is really short notice and first of all
this is less than a week away however if
you don't
anything else on them please find it in
your heart to attend my gathering and if
you aren't going to attend then please
leave me like a comment or a video
response just so I can get like a
general idea of how many people are
coming and whatever you do please don't
forget to bring me presents please okay
I'm sorry I'm sorry
so here around 30 minutes later I've
just finished editing that video and I'm
thinking you know what you guys probably
deserve a reasoning as to why I decided
to call my gathering David well I'll be
honest I'm a big Doctor Who fan and I
might have a slight heterosexual man
crush on David Tennant but don't tell
anyone okay the secrets